there is stunning footage that has been leaked
from the archives of NBC News of Donald Trump
hanging out with accused serial rapist, Jeffrey
Epstein in 1992 talking to Epstein about a
gaggle of young women who were dancing in
front of them at a private party.
So we need to end this world in which the
Trump is right, is allowed to weave what is
a complete fantasy world that it's simply
unbelievable that Donald Trump could have
at any point been involved in any kind of
sexual assault with Jeffrey Epstein or at
Jeffrey Epstein's Manhattan Condo because
they barely knew each other.
They weren't friends.
Trump never liked him.
It needs to stop.
Okay.
And corporate media, by the way.
It needs to stop giving any benefit of the
doubt to that narrative that Donald Trump
has been trying to weave.
Donald Trump to catch you up, was accused
of raping a 13 year old girl that also claims
Jeffrey Epstein raped her.
Uh, and that, uh, the suit was ultimately
pulled because of alleged death threats against
the 13 year old.
The, then 13 year old Donald Trump's outgoing
labor secretary Alexander Acosta gave Jeffrey
Epstein a ridiculously good plea deal years
ago, and he now has been forced to resign
as a result of it.
Donald Trump has claimed at time, and again,
he never liked Jeffrey Epstein.
Never was really a fan, never really hung
out with Jeffrey Epstein, barely knew the
guy.
And this, every single day is a narrative
that is being absolutely destroyed by facts
and evidence.
There's now newly discovered footage from
the NBC archives, which shows that Donald
Trump was not only talking to Jeffrey Epstein
after warmly welcoming him to his party in
1992, he was clearly talking on video about
the young women that were dancing in front
of them, who's hot whispering sweet nothings
into Jeffrey Epstein's ear about who knows
what it is that maybe Jeffrey Epstein might
be interested in doing later on at that party.
So this is video, uh, from well before the
sickening plea deal that Epstein ultimately
struck in Florida.
Let's take a look at the video.
Yeah.
A tape in the NBC archives of a Mar-a-lago
Party shows Trump giving Epstein his personal
attention.
The footage shot in November of 1992 the throw
Trump open the resort as a club shows the
future president surrounded by cheerleaders
for the buffalo bills and Miami dolphins capturing
Trump's fun loving bachelor lifestyle for
an appearance on faith, Daniel's NBC talk
show.
We're going to get great ratings in your show.
Trump is surrounded by women as music players
in the background.
After a while, Trump votes to greet three
new guests.
Among them, the financee are Jeffrey Epstein
more than a decade before his guilty plea
on state prostitution charges.
Later in the footage Trump the same talking
to Epstein and another man as women are dancing
in front of them.
Trump alternates between dancing and pointing
out women to Epstein and the other man and
telling Epstein about the cameras.
No,
exactly.
What they say is difficult to understand as
they discuss the women and their appearances.
Trump gestures to one and appears to say to
Epstein, look at her back there.
She's hot
[inaudible]
and then Trump says something else into Epstein's
ear.
That makes him double over with laughter.
But as the president says now, he never liked
Epstein.
I was not a fan of his that I can tell you
I was not a fan of this.
So this is actually even worse than previously
imagined.
I hope you notice, by the way, if you were
watching the video, if not, find the audio,
find the video because the audio doesn't do
it.
Justice Trump at one point grabbing a woman's
rear end in the video.
That's a really nice touch.
So Trump has said, I barely knew.
The guy seems to know him pretty well based
on this video.
All of the prior reporting on this has been
accurate.
Trump was friends with Epstein.
Trump was accused of raping a 13 year old
in Epstein's Manhattan apartment.
But the picture is now sort of expanding to
show this as a two way relationship, which
is what quite frankly most of us believed
it to be.
Most of us in the side of logic and reason
believed it to be from the beginning of the
evidence that we started gathering on this
issue.
Not only was Epstein possibly facilitating
trysts for Donald Trump at Epstein's homes,
going back to the nineties Trump was potentially
facilitating trysts for Epstein at Trump's
own properties.
Especially.
Remember we heard early this week or late
last week about the party planner who is told
to gather 28 young women for a party which
would be attended only by those 28 young women
as well as Donald Trump and Jeffrey Epstein.
So consider how much we have to suspend disbelief
in order to believe the right wing talking
points on this Trump now, he didn't like Epstein.
Well, we've got footage.
Where do they certainly seem to like each
other?
Trump now, he didn't go to parties with young
girls along with Epstein, except now there's
video of Epstein going to Trump's parties
with young women.
Why is it so difficult to imagine that sometimes
the parties would be at Epstein's place as
well, their relationship, oh, it was distant.
They were definitely not bonding over women.
They found attractive.
Oh wait, now there's video of Trump and Epstein
gawking at women dancing while Donald Trump
discusses with Epstein, which ones are attractive
and how attractive are they?
Trump is on video saying, you just do what
you want when you're famous, grab them by
the Pussy.
And then in the video that is uncovered by
NBC, he is literally grabbing a woman's rear
end without it being clear if that's actually
what she wants to have happen.
But we're supposed to believe that it's all
unsubstantiated attack rumors meant to make
Donald Trump look bad.
Remember, there were no such allegations against
Barack Obama, another Democratic president,
a Democratic president.
There were no such allegations against George
W. Bush, a republican president.
This is not just par for the course where
every president is not only accused of a dozen
sexual assaults, but there's video evidence
of them in cahoots with individuals with whom
they allegedly conspired on some of these
sexual assaults.
It's all on video.
The grab them by the pussy tape.
Now this video court documents from multiple
women, including Trump's own ex wife saying,
he raped me, he assaulted me.
But we have to pretend like idiots.
Oh, we don't know.
There's no real evidence.
Will there ever be responsibility for having
elected a serial sex assault or to the presidency?
Not If Trumpists have any say.
And increasingly, you know, impeachment would
take a while.
Removal by the 25th amendment would take a
while.
Actual consequences for all of these alleged
sexual assaults by Donald Trump may never
happen, but we can remove the guy in November
in 2020 and in November of 2020 and I hope
that we do do that.
Let me know what you think about this latest
video.
Uh, I'm on Twitter at d pacman.
If you're not following me on Twitter, please
follow me on Twitter.
Had An interesting little exchange this morning
actually that gave Ruben, then you can see
there
also, while you're on Twitter, you might as
well follow at David Pakman show as well.